the grand dame of science is to figure
out how it all works which includes
giant questions like where did the
universe come from what's it really made
of how does all of that stuff work and
interact with each other and how is it
that human intelligence exists I was
able to experience the universe and
probe it with our minds you know small
stuff like that ever since someone stood
underneath the starry sky looked up and
went ugh
people have been asking these questions
we can see forms of science as far back
as the ancient Mesopotamians and
Egyptians but the theory of science has
its roots in philosophy with the Greek
philosopher Aristotle being the first to
think about how to actually go about
doing science this methodology has been
refined over the ages and is now called
the philosophy of science this core of
science is the scientific method which
contains principles like logic
rationalism empiricism evidence testable
hypotheses objectivity and reductionism
this is the toolkit of science and helps
us process the information we get about
the universe to work out what is and
isn't true mathematics and computer
science are not technically Sciences
because they don't study the natural
world but they're very close to science
and are incredibly useful tools for
scientists to use mathematics is the
machinery of physics and it's kind of a
mystery why mathematics describes the
universe so well computers are used in
all branches of science because to do
science you need a brain and computers
are an amazing tool to augment our
brains the Kouros science is made of
physics chemistry and biology which
contain a load of surrounding
disciplines as well I don't have space
to include them all but I have done in
depth maps of all of these subjects so
check out those if you want to find out
more if you take a step back and look at
all of science is interesting to see how
the scientific method changes as you
apply it to different subjects physics
made huge amounts of progress to
understand the universe through
reductionism breaking things apart into
their smallest components and
understanding them one by one but when
you move up the chain towards chemistry
and biology reduct
becomes increasingly difficult to apply
because these subjects deal with much
more complex systems if you want to
study a part of biology the properties
of a single thing are strongly defined
by its relationships with everything
else you can no longer study individual
pieces in isolation because removing
them from their relationships actually
changes the thing you want to study so
there are so many complicated
relationships in things like how your
genes in your DNA are expressed to make
you or how your neurons and neural
chemistry all combine to create the
unique experience that you're having now
these systems emerge out of a massive
number of very complicated relationships
and so capturing all of that complexity
in one model is incredibly hard in fact
as we get further and further up the
chain away from physics the entire
scientific method starts breaking apart
you can see this in fields like
nutrition and psychology are incredibly
important historical results are looking
increasingly questionable like eating
saturated fat leading to high
cholesterol or how it's hard to
replicate the results of many famous
psychology studies like willpower being
a limited resource but I think that
these mistakes are understandable
because trying to come up with a
scientific theory that explains why
people do the things that people do is
just a very hard thing to do because
people are complicated and in fact
there's an argument that the human brain
is the most complex system that we know
about in the universe and so when you
get a whole load of those together doing
stuff like in sociology
it just gets it just gets crazy which
brings us to the Social Sciences which
I've arranged vaguely for more sciency
to less sciency these subjects often
contain a mixture of scientific
practices and practices from the
humanities like archaeology which uses
hard science techniques from physics to
detect
as under the ground or carbon-date
objects but then the interpretation of
what this evidence tells us about the
humans that lived at that time becomes a
lot more subjective or in fields like
economics or political science where
people can apply rigorous statistical
techniques to their data but then the
interpretation of those has to be done
by a human brain
who is by nature subjective so the proof
that these interpretations are not
scientific is the fact that they can't
predict the future
so in economics it seems we can't
predict when a recessions going to
happen or what bitcoins gonna do
tomorrow
whereas in physics if I throw a ball I
can describe the future of that ball
incredibly well but please note that I'm
not saying that subjectivity is
necessarily a bad thing if you're
studying a subject matter that has these
very complex systems in them and you've
taken the scientific method to its
breaking point what else you gonna do
subjectivity really is all you have left
but the trouble comes when it's not
recognized or flagged appropriately
people think they're being objective
when they're actually being subjective
and that does happen but this is forcing
people to innovate with a scientific
method and come up with new techniques
to deal with these systems one example
from history are randomized control
trials in the pharmaceutical industry to
really tell whether a drug is working or
not and with the recent crisis in
replication crisis in the social
sciences scientists are now trying to
come up with new techniques and
methodologies to deal with these
complicated systems and is a very hard
challenge but that's how you progress
but if you want to get at the truth of
something in the world the scientific
method is still our best way of doing
that but now let's carry on our journey
and leave the burden of scientific rigor
behind us and move into the arts a place
of pure subjectivity is this good art
well I like it okay the one thing they
do share with science is exploration
pushing the limits of what has been done
or thought
for they explore the human condition
through books movies music art and
always try to find new ways of
reflecting on what it is to be alive and
a human with emotions and a brain with
the ability to create and I think it's
just as well that we can't explain all
of those things with science because
they'd lose all of their charm that
intangible nature is what makes them so
much fun some of the most enduring art
has tackled the biggest questions like
what is it to be human why are we here
and what should we do with our time here
these are very similar to where we
started and brings us right back to the
other side of philosophy so I got a bit
carried away this map isn't really a map
of science it's a map of human endeavor
and it isn't even a map but a giant
cosmic doughnut of knowledge
anyway that's it
thanks for watching and if you want to
get hold of the donor of knowledge check
out the link in the description below to
get a poster and if you yourself want to
learn some science I would recommend
checking out the sponsor to this video
brilliant org it's a website where you
learn a lot of the core concepts in this
map like mathematics computer science
physics and many more and you learn them
by answering questions so in general
when you're learning a subject you might
feel like you know it there's only one
way to make sure and that's by actually
answering questions to test your
knowledge that's using the scientific
method on yourself so that's what you do
on brilliant org you learn by answering
questions but they're fun and engaging
they're very satisfying when you get one
right and if you get one wrong there's
lots of help and descriptions to help
you work out why so if that sounds
interesting check out brilliant org
slash do S link is also in the
description below it and as an added
bonus the first 200 people to sign up
can get a 20% discount off the annual
premium membership which unlocks all of
their content so check that out and also
we've just released the next in there
professor Astro cap books which is a
space Rockets book so if you've got a
youngster in your life who you'd like to
get into science at a young age at a
really good place to start
links also in the description below well
that's it for me thanks so much for
watching and I'll see you on the next
video
[Music]